and there's other so there's other
trends that I see okay and I see this
trend of women monetizing Beauty right
so I mean women tend to make a lot of
money in jobs that monetize Beauty so I
use Kim Kardashian as an example very
often
um but it's not the only thing let's
let's think of assistant work I mean
guys want a pretty girl at the front of
the office
um when another one I think of is sales
like there's um I can't remember the
name it's it's medical medical sales I
think it's called
um
it's all like hot 22 year olds and they
kind of know they're gonna age out
eventually and one thing that I see is
ex-strippers and sex workers uh going
into politics and this is why I openly
say that women should not be in politics
I don't really care if chicks you know
if we want to like you know you know
there's always been political women
right there there's always been women
that have political movements and like
writers that that is like guys
Housewives have done that women have
always done that but what is abnormal in
this time period is women that run for
an office that's abnormal women should
not one be able to vote and have
political power
um and two because men have always
looked out for women's best interests
think about it guys we could be sex like
we could be sex slaves right now in
cages if all the men got together and
said this is what we're gonna do but no
men would never let other men do that
even the men that want to do that if
they do do that you know they go to jail
and Men protect us men have always
looked out for women's best interests
but women just don't we just tend to
look out for ourselves when men win
everybody wins but when we win we win
for ourselves so there was a democratic
of course Virginia House of delegates
candidate Susanna Gibson who's facing a
scandal as videos of her and her husband
engaging in sexual acts for money on
this adult streaming website chat
ChatterBait have surfaced despite the
Revelation Gibson has condemned her
political opponents accusing them of
resorting to gutter politics and framing
the release of these videos as an
illegal invasion of privacy her attorney
Daniel P Watkins is pursuing legal
action under Virginia's revenge porn law
asserting that the videos were
maliciously disseminated okay what guys
you can tell it's feminist when
like what does that mean maliciously
disseminated so you know the Dylan
danison Logan Paul's situation I could
kind of see if they you can't hack
people's phones right that you can't
that's essentially like going into
someone's house and like taking their
stuff right you can't do that but
um I mean porn that they put on the
internet for free the Republican
candidate David Owen expressed sympathy
for Gibson and remained focused on his
campaign the controversy has emerged in
a highly competitive race for a seat in
the house of delegates with significant
implications for party control in the
state as both parties invest heavily in
the campaign Gibson apparently
maintained her ChatterBait profile
called hot wife experience after having
announced her campaign in July 2022
uploading at least one image of herself
on the sex streaming site a month later
she garnered
5770 ChatterBait followers whom she
repeatedly pressed for more tokens in
exchange for certain acts and private
showings she told her fans that she was
raising money for a good cause the state
Republican party and house Speaker Todd
Gilbert did not immediately respond to
the post request for comment on Tuesday
that let me get this straight let me get
this straight
um decided to put images of her and her
husband having sex online
in charge of making decisions for the
country
predict that there's there's so many
former only fans workers strippers Etc
that just run for office because they
need attention and they just they they
just it's really a mockery of the
American judicial system and legal
system
and political system like we need to get
these women out of office women should
not hold political power
you know I swear I've always thought
about I've thought about I should run
for office just to take away women's
rights because that's the only solution
I see going forward but you know there's
another school of thought that's once
once we open this Pandora's Box you
can't go back and now we adapt I don't
know and now we get the artificial wombs
is that the future
it's really
I I think there's two options here you
go into modern times and just become
more modern or you take away women's
rights you know either or